what do you think of sean carroll's
many worlds well it's not his many
worlds interpretation but
he seems to think it's the only game in
town with regard to
quantum mechanical interpretations
and he seems to think it's not as
arbitrary as people say
and that maybe there's some evidence for
it at least if you quote unquote follow
the math so what do you make of that
argument um
well so quantum mechanics was discovered
experimentally and that's an important
lesson for us to maintain our humility
as scientists
you know sometimes we need the
experiments to to to give us an insight
about nature that we haven't expected
and it takes us out of our comfort zone
and he took albert einstein out of his
comfort zone because he thought that
you can't have quantum mechanics with a
spooky action at a distance it makes no
sense to him
uh
and so he wrote a paper about it
at the einstein podolsky roseanne paper
trying to propose an experiment that
will
demonstrate that spooky action at the
distance does not exist and
versions of that experiment were done
and he was proven wrong
and indeed we are a century later after
quantum mechanics was discovered still
feeling uneasy about how to interpret it
um and
this is an excellent example for why we
need experiments because
uh very often
experiments open us our eyes to
facts that we you know we haven't
anticipated that our imagination is
limited the
more limited than nature's imagination
in a way
and we we should
science is basically
um
just being a student for life
as a scientist you are you have to be
humble and modest enough to admit that
you know that perhaps nature
is different than your preconceptions
and if you were to say i don't need
verification i know the truth in advance
i know that there are extra dimensions
or i know that um
was a rock
or i know that this and that without
even checking then you are just like the
philosophers during the days of galileo
that didn't want to look through his
telescope because they knew that the sun
moves around the earth
so just i just wanted to to make that
point that the quantum mechanics is
really a
an excellent example of why a scientist
we should always regard ourselves as
students of nature
uh but coming back to so
to the question of what's the meaning of
quantum mechanics that as you mentioned
that the there was the many world
interpretation and uh sean carroll puts
it in a modern context
and
obviously does sean carroll add anything
that hasn't been said before on the many
worlds interpretation from everett
um
yeah i mean
there are some new nuances now
that relate
to how to to define the wave function
and the possible existence of the
multiverse that some people
contemplate as
you know that the actual
reality is much uh
bigger than what we can
experiment with within the observable
universe that we see
um
but then i would say that the verdict is
still out i mean
every year or two i read the an
interesting essay that uh offers new
insights to quantum mechanics the
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
we are not there yet we we haven't
converged on something that everyone
agrees on and again i think the way to
converge would be to be guided by
experiments and and it's quite possible
you know that the one thing we're
missing is the connection with gravity
that we don't have a quantum theory of
gravity that was tested experimentally
and perhaps in the context of such a
theory
the
the concerns we have we will go away
because one thing that you recognize in
quantum mechanics at least the
traditional way it was formulated in
is that time plays a special role
relative to space and
um
whereas in in in the general theory of
relativity time and space are just
dimensions of space time and
they can be curved by
objects and so forth
so perhaps once we
identify a winning theory that unifies
quantum mechanics and gravity many of
the
ambiguities that we have right now in
physics and by the way there are many
not just not just the interpretation of
quantum mechanics the
there is the information paradox in the
context of black holes um we don't know
what happens to information that falls
into a black hole
um
stephen hawking demonstrated that black
holes evaporate eventually into thermal
radiation that doesn't carry that
information so the question is if the
black hole goes away where where are all
where is all the information that we
threw into it when we made it
uh and that's a fundamental question
because quantum mechanics
argues that information cannot be
destroyed and
so this is one puzzle that is also
unsolved in modern physics then there is
a question of what happens in the
singularities of either the singularity
of a black hole where the curvature of
space and time diverges
or the singularity of the big bang what
happened before the big bang